I gotta tell you my works not always
easy I mean granted this is the greatest
job in the world but whenever somebody
asks you what did you do it your job
today and you had to answer i watch Care
Bears the movie I got a little inside
yeah I die a little how can anyone say
that with any shred of dignity
how can anyone speak that with any pride
you can't roll it hammer that is a place
we
yes the characters were pretty big in
their day disgustingly cute disgustingly
nice and disgustingly marketable look at
any child not get wrapped up and they're
disgusting this so when this movie came
out children roared with applause and
parents cringed in fear knowing that
they would have to sit through this
technical involved is it as bad as it
looks
well there's only one way to find that
let's take a look at Care Bears the
movie so we start off with probably the
whitest orphanage ever seen on film as
our narrator named mr. cherrywood comes
in now off to sleep to dream of clowns
and circuses acrobats and jugglers he's
played by Mickey Rooney former biggest
star in the world but now doing no
carrot
he decides to tell the children a story
before they go to sleep this is the
story of two young children named Kim
and Jason and how they were helped by a
group of very special friends the Care
Bears oh I don't want the face II made
their the Care Bears
okay face that says I touched half of
these children and I'm okay with that
the Care Bears live in a magic place
called Caroline so it's the crunch roll
we get our opening song called Caroline
somebody Carole King is in that sound
and is it me or does she sound totally
uninterested in singing Cara
is a place
you like to be
riding on a cloud
or not it's a rainbow
for laughing out loud
Karen Mott is paying for my new car so
might as well do it on top of that this
song is just shit I mean listen to these
lyrics Caroline carousels playing music
in your mind for dancing and singing
sometimes you feel so glad sometimes you
feel blue trust your feelings it's not
bad feelings are just you what does that
even mean feelings are just you all
that's good to know I thought was
Hershel the feeling fairy what are they
talking about by the way it's probably
my perverted mind but what does it look
like these two are doing this fair looks
way too happy about what this bear is
doing I think that car is just a cover
so our story begins when they spot two
children who you guessed it stopped
caring hi I'm Fran bear and this is
secret bear we're Care Bears what do you
want only to be your friends actually I
always wonder what counted as
quote/unquote carry I mean if I'm
ordering a pizza with a friend is it
like what kind of toppings you want I
don't care no way oh hi where are the
Care Bears and everybody has to care
about something
everyone needs friends Jason even you
and Kim we're not your friends how do
you know her name's really that's your
biggest question right now I mean
granted that's a legit query but that
should be like question number five we
know a lot of things about you
Kim reads a lot of books and wants to be
a nurse when she grows up and Jason you
want to be a jet pilot yeah how did you
know that friends are supposed to know
about each other's hopes and dreams
friends stalkers it's all good so while
they try to comfort the two kids they're
mainly learning tender heart goes to
check on another kid named Nicolas
Nicolas was a magician's helper he had
never had a friend in his life hey close
the dole oh this is why you've never had
a friend in your life I didn't mean it I
bought that trunk thinking maybe there's
some junk in it I can use in my magic
act now half of its broken don't make me
tell your parents who may or may not
exist and I may or may not be keeping
you from but Nikolas comes across a
secret magic book Nikolas I am a spirit
Nikolas your friend unfortunately it's a
book that seems to possess unnatural
evil power this is your chance to show
that you are a greater magician than he
they love him for his magic they love
you
it was never meant for the world of the
living
well that's going on though the campers
are working on their latest invention a
teleport yes apparently there's
groundbreaking scientific technology and
care-a-lot as long as the buttons look
like Lucky Charms marshmallows but it
accidentally beans the two children up
when I wasn't supposed to where are we
my friends felt like these kids they
have all the right reactions so while
they trying to get the teleporter to
work they show the kids around Caroline
via a god-awful song sequence
nobody cares like a big fashion what's
your evil book again you'll be in a deep
sleep only long enough for you to take
over his magic show but but I I couldn't
yes you can you must
so this genuinely creepy character that
appears has simply known as the spirit
oh well not flat-out scary there is
something very threatening about her
maybe it's her voice maybe it's the fact
that there's just no face in a book but
there's something that's just a little
unsettling cat essence children
waiting to see your match in fact I
don't want watch her anymore I'm going
to fast forward pass her parts
ah I've seen a book so in touch with
evils it's Twilight Nicholas stop this
isn't the way to make friends there was
he when you needed him what mattered it
just long Nicholas's face here as if to
say wow I really didn't think I was
gonna see this today a talking bear
speaking with an evil face in a walk
thank God it's at least Friday so she
wants tender heart in a cage and
convinces Nicholas to start his own
magic show magic isn't the answer
Nicholas your feelings can help you find
a true answer yes just listen to the
magic talking bear so tender heart
breaks his way out as Nicholas's magic
show doesn't go as well as you plan we
can stop laughing only you can do it
simmers sot cos Orkney
now we turn them into YouTube commenters
bacon so Nicholas has evil books start
turning everybody in the world in ten
sharks because of this Kara lot starts
to trouble the caring meter dropped 200
we're reaching Jersey levels the Jersey
levels so Kim and Jason decide to join
the Care Bears in their mission to stop
the spirit hold on to this for me Jason
don't lose it it's very important then
why don't you hold on to it well anyway
in Troy teleporting them to Earth but
the earthquake destroys the teleporter
in the process they never made it to
earth what do you mean where are they
they're lost somewhere between here and
Earth yeah um what exactly is the
cosmology for Carolina anyway I thought
was in the clouds now it's in a
different dimension I mean where are
they expected to end up they're lashed
somewhere between here and Earth
so they decided to take a river down to
earth that's right there's a river in
the clouds now in the hope that this
will somehow cross dimensions I don't
know here's how they explained it no one
in care-a-lot had ever followed the
river they had no idea whether it would
lead them to Kim Jason and the missing
Care Bears
what in the world on holes in your story
was a river in the sky they just never
questioned why with there followed it
what they have a giant sailboat on
standby quiet or I will smack you with
my ring hand so Jason Kim and the other
two Care Bears are trapped in between
worlds which I guess is filled with lost
cereal mascots everyone in the forest of
feelings knows of playful heart monkey
and brave heart I know how could I not
put at it so even though they're lost in
the forest of feelings the people of
Earth are deteriorating and Caroline is
falling apart that doesn't stop our
heroes from having a song number do you
have a house maid
out of wood for keeping you dry with a
grading whoa that's pretty bad kid I
mean not only am hung bad but stay
perfectly still
that was totally necessary what was the
movie like 20 seconds too short so you
had to add a B C the song is pointless
enough already you don't need any more
pad
meanwhile Nikolas and the spear
continued to turn all the people of the
world into rap nail these two small
children still care but they were to
fall under my spell
those little bear shield them from your
spells within love and caring what is up
with this woman's voice is someone just
eating her out while she's saying her
lines
that's cute cuddly little bit ah oh oh
the castle I don't know oh you must
finish it sad
zip
oh great you are leash tail the
apocalypse is finally begun and Satan is
going to roll here
good job oh go so that purple fart goes
to find the others that's the Care Bear
ship once across more friends that they
can make good toys out
I'm coffee hot penguin helping someone
in need is what plums my heart and keeps
me cozy only 995 has to scream and yell
at your parents until they finally break
down and buy you on it's more important
than reading
they also come across a pink elephant
and guessing the amount of booze you've
probably had throughout this picture I'm
guessing you're coming across a few as
one things aren't so hot we can and
chasin as the purple smoke possesses the
only tree that happens to have an evil
face
hey George you need to go ladies but the
level Ching I'm visiting Wow fail the
luckily speedy gun hoppers comes along
to save the day so the new bunny friend
joins them on their adventure but
unfortunately the purple smoke takes on
another four you know you're really bad
at that just think of your brave doesn't
mean you're capable our only hope is a
Care Bear stare I just hope it works
there's only two of us the two of us
aren't enough taste the rainbow
motherfucker
yeah well fuck hearing the answer this
problem was violence wonderful caring
violence Oh
so together all the other animals of the
forest because there weren't enough
fucking toys to sell as they find their
way out of the forest and back to her
how lucky the river just so happens to
pass space and time do you still have
the key that I gave you sure do if we
lose that key Jason we can never win
that's why I'm entrusting it to a small
boy I barely know houses make sense
again so Nicholas cassis spell to turn
Kim and Jason into heartless jerks but
he needs them to be close in order for
the spell to work
Nicola you're too late too late I can
officially become a vampire not one of
those sparkling ones though they totally
suck ass the campers try to stop him but
the evil of the book is just way too
strong the spirit's power is too strong
look oh this kid could totally give the
effort from Star Wars a run for his
money
no young Skywalker
you will die the camera has tried to
stare him down as the other animals try
to help everybody call
okay and then you get up I don't know a
gun or some kind of blunt instrument or
Kim she should know them
Oh Lord what is up with this kid's face
he's show me the judge doom from Who
Framed Roger Rabbit where I killed your
brother
I talked doesn't like those literally
brick we care about you we used to be
like you we thought nobody cared but we
were wrong now we want to be your
friends Nicholas
okay you know the drill the kids start
saying that they care about Nicholas
which gives him the will to care and
thus he stopped using the bar Josephine
ha ha hold on Nicholas Hey what the hell
so the key they kept building up this
whole time as the big secret weapon can
be duplicated whatever they want
what could they just want make the
little boy feel important so Carol
otters say the two kids get adopted and
Nicholas finally perfects his magic Care
Bears also welcome two new animal
friends to be Care Bears lions whatever
that's they celebrate by dancing like
they have a dump in their mail and it
turns out all the children in the
orphanage fell asleep no doubt bored
senseless of mr. cherrywood story now
they'll never know what eventually
became of Nicholas I guess all they need
to know is that he too lived happily
ever after
happier than I ever thought I could be
good story but he missed the part about
the sodomy and the ties to the JFK
assassination but I get that stuff
wasn't very important
so that's the Care Bears movie how does
it hold up here well yeah it's stupid
but to be fair it's for little kids it's
kind of hard to beat up on something
intended from really young children it's
not good but there's not really anything
bad in it for kids it's relatively
harmless so if you're ages 1 to I don't
know one you'll probably enjoy it okay
but there's still one thing that really
bothers me
why was the book so evil I mean what was
her motivation all this time it doesn't
make an exact thing opens up a cryptic
you wanted to know what my motivation
lies yes yeah it was to make the people
of the web stop caring I knew that but
why do you want that to begin I don't
know I don't care oh I see because you
don't care nobody else cared grounds
yeah kind of a funny taste a bit yeah
this'll wait wait no I can give you a
happy ending I'm gonna stop you Greg I
remember it so you don't have to hail a
robot is a place where
whenever we choose beyond bears nose